One important decision in the design of the
modern routers was to place a copy of
the forwarding table on each line card in
the router. Well, this introduces some complications in
making copies of the forwarding table. Doing so,
prevents a central table on the router from
becoming a bottleneck at high speeds. Consider an
alternative where the router only has one copy of
forwarding table. . In that case all of the
line cards would need to be performing look ups on
a central table. Which involves communication across the back
plane as well as many more look ups against a
central table. So while distributing the forwarding table across
line cards prevents a central table from becoming a bottleneck.
Early router architectures did not place the look up table
on each line card, and as a result, when packets
arrived at an individual line card, they would induce
a look up in a shared buffer memory which
could be accessed over a shared bus. But this
shared bus, of course, introduces a bottleneck as well
as contention between the different line cards that may
be all performing lookups to the same shared memory.
The solution, of course, was thus to remove the
shared memory and instead place copies of the forwarding
table on each line card. In summary, An
important innovation in the design of these router
was to eliminate the shared bus and place
the look up table on individual line bus.